يعني مشكله جامده يعني انا كنت ناوي اجيب
الاجهزه الكهربائيه كلها مره واحده دلوقتي
هجيب على الاقل نص الاجهزه انا بتكلم
دلوقتي في بعض الاجهزه داخله في 60 الف
جنيه الاثار السلبيه للحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وارتفاع الاسعار عالميا فاقم
ازمه الدولار التي ادت الى ارتفاع غير
مسبوق في الاسعار بعد تخفيض قيمه الجني
اكثر من مره ومنذ مارس من العام الماضي
فرضت الحكومه قيودا على الاستيراد لتقليل
استنزاف العمله الاجنبيه ما ادى الى تناقص
الاجهزه الكهربائيه في الاسواق سواء
المستورده او المنتجه محليا وتعتمد على
مكون اجنبي في التصنيع هذا النقص ادى الى
ظهور سوق سوداء للاجهزه واستغلال من بعض
التجار بمضاعفه الاسعار
الرسمي ما ينفعش ان انا اطلعه اكتر من
فاتوره الضريبيه بسعره الرسمي لكن المشكله
مثلا في تاجر مثلا محطوط في منطقه مثلا
معزوله مش مسجل مش مش بيلم البضاعه من
السوق وبيروح يبدا يبيع بسعره وهو عايزه
الرقابه موجوده الرقابه ما بتبقاش موجوده
اعلى مش مكشوف حركه البيع الاول كانت
شغاله بسبب المنتجات الكتير دلوقتي
منتجات وقلت حركه البيع بسبب زياده
الاسعار طبعا انت كل يوم في تغيير اسعار
المصانع خفضت طاقتها الانتاجيه بسبب نقص
مكونات التصنيع المستورده ما ادى الى
انخفاض المعروض وبرغم الافراج الجمركي عن
البضائع المكدسه في الموانئ منذ يناير
الماضي بقيمه نحو ثلاثه وعشرين مليار
دولار الا ان الاولويه منحت للسلع
الاساسيه والادويه وبعض مستلزمات الانتاج
من ضمن الحلول
المقترحه ان يسيبوا الناس تدبر دولار
لمعرفتهم لكن ده للاسف نتيجته انه هيرفع
سعر الدولار في السوق السوداء اللي الحل
التاني هو حل طويل الاجل ان البلد تبتدي
بمبادرات انها تصنع كل ما يتم استيراده
احنا ابتدينا فعلا او في مبادرات رئاسيه
اللي هي مبادره ابدا بدات في القصه دي لكن
عشان يطلع نتيجه للكلام ده احنا قدامنا
سنوات اه ما بين توفير الدولار واستقرار
سعر الصرف يبقى الحل طويل الامد الذي بدات
بوادره بمبادرات عبر التوسع في استخدام
المكونات المحليه في التصنيع راندا ابو
العزم العربيه القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات